the middle joint found in eight of your
toes is called the proximal
interphalangeal or pip joint
hammer toe and claw toe are conditions
where one or more of your toes stays in
an abnormally bent position
if you have a hammer toe the pip joint
is bent so that your toe looks like a
hammer
if you have a claw toe the joint where
your foot until meet is bent upward
while the pip joint is bent downward
this makes your toe look like a claw
if non-surgical treatments don't work
your health care provider may advise you
to have a surgical procedure such as pip
arthroplasty and fusion to straighten
your toe
to start the procedure your surgeon will
make an incision on the top of your toe
ligaments and tendons over the toe bones
may be cut to expose the joint
next the ends of the two bones will be
removed
this allows more room for the toe to
relax and straighten
sometimes a pin or other fixation device
will be inserted through the bones to
keep your toes straight while it heals
at the end of the procedure the incision
will be closed with sutures
your surgeon may also place your toe in
a cast or splint while it heals
as the joint heals scar tissue will form
fusing the two bones together
if a pin is used it will be removed in
your doctor's office after a few weeks
to find out more about hammer toe or
claw toe procedures talk to your health
care provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you